[Music]
[Applause]
please be seated
graduates honored guests faculty staff
families and friends welcome to the 2019
graduation ceremony at the Stanford
University Graduate School of Business
I would like to begin by recognizing the
people around us who have played a
pivotal role in the experience of our
graduates the faculty that sit behind me
have let our students on a
transformative journey could I ask the
faculty to stand for a moment of facts
around the pavilion our staff from the
mba MSX and PhD programs whose
dedication and effort have helped make
the journey meaningful could I ask our
staff to stand and be recognized
we are joined by families and friends
who have provided support advice a
friendly ear and most importantly love
let's take a moment to recognize our
families and friends
a Stanford Graduate School of Business
opened in 1925 it was the brainchild of
Herbert Hoover a Stanford trustee who
was soon to become president of the
United States Hoover was concerned that
talented young business people were
leaving California for the East Coast
he proposed that Stamford start a
business school on the west coast the
American frontier it would have a
regional focus and blend teaching and
research he estimated that launching the
new venture would have a total cost of
$50,000 a year
[Applause]
from those beginnings a great deal has
changed if you look across this arena
you will see students from across the
country and across the world who speak
more than 70 languages
[Applause]
we are today vastly more interconnected
technology is vastly more advanced
management continues to evolve we have a
broader notion of how Business School
can educate leaders for all types of
organizations and careers you our
graduates reflect those changes yet
elements of Hoover's vision remain
Stanford still sits on the American
frontier the frontier of innovation and
discovery in coming to Stanford you have
journeyed to that frontier you have
learned about what the future might hold
the way new ideas and technologies will
reshape our lives the way business and
society will need to adapt you have
learned about the human aspects of
organizations in leadership how to work
with others how to build a culture how
to listen communicate inspire as leaders
of the future you will have to be
attentive to both technology and people
you will need to think beyond yourselves
about the impact your organizations have
on the world leadership is about the
people around you and the strategic
choices and consequences of your
decisions maintaining this breadth of
perspective the micro and the macro will
be essential in realizing your
collective potential I am confident you
are well-prepared you have learned from
extraordinary faculty you have made
friends from around the world heard
their stories and created new ones you
have developed a range of talents from
entrepreneurship to investing to public
speaking to musical theater
this afternoon you walk across the stage
and graduate but your GSP connections
will continue you will remain an
important part of the school I would
like to finish with a story about those
connections and how they persist in
unexpected but meaningful ways
some time ago I was visiting China is it
a hotel in Beijing with a few GSB alumni
talking to a group of Chinese reporters
a fellow walks past and seeing Stanford
GSB on the door walks into the room it
turns out he's from Mexico he's in China
for his wedding anniversary and he's a
GSB alum naturally the reporters
immediately asked him about the GSB I'll
admit I'm a little nervous
I thought this fellow before he's just
wandered into this hotel conference room
I'm wondering what he's gonna say about
the school that will show up the next
day in the newspaper for 1.3 billion
potential readers so he tells a story
about being a student at the GSB and
having a beer with a classmate who's
decided to move to Seattle to join a
brand new computer company the story
unfolds
turns out the classmate is Steve Ballmer
the company is Microsoft the stories
about technology and human connection
the reporters are impressed
then our alum who's just happened on
this meeting thousands of miles from
homes as actually that's not really the
main point I graduated from Stanford 35
years ago I've worked in many
organizations and many industries what
the GSB taught me was how to change all
of them for the better I am impressed
class of 2019 wherever you go may this
place always be with you and follow you
in all your endeavors and be a home for
you when you return I am excited to see
what you accomplished in your lives and
in the world I know you will make us
proud congratulations grad
[Music]
now it is my great pleasure to introduce
Lord John Brown Lord Brown grew up and
was educated in Great Britain
he joined British Petroleum while still
in University and worked in exploration
and production around the world in 1981
he was a Sloan fellow at the GSB
graduating with an MS and management
John returned to British Petroleum
rising through the ranks and maintaining
his close connections with the school
through executive programs and as a
member of the GSB is Advisory Council in
1995 John became chief executive of BP
and led the company through a golden
decade of expansion and diversification
in one of the defining moments of his
tenure John returned to Stanford in 1997
and gave a landmark speech recognising
the importance of climate change and the
need to address it he was the first CEO
of a major oil company to do so and he
subsequently sought to rethink ep's
future beyond petroleum John Stanford
speech is credited with helping the
shift global politics and set the stage
for the passage of the Kyoto Protocol in
1998 since stepping down from BP John
has been a member of the UK House of
Lords a government adviser the president
of the Royal Academy of Engineering and
the author of several business books
these include beyond business the glass
closet about coming out as LGBT and the
importance of inclusive corporate
cultures and most recently make think
imagine engineering the future of
civilization john has a remarkable
perspective on global business on
corporate culture and unperson 'el
leadership it has been my pleasure to
get to know him and learn from him and
I'm delighted to have him back at the
GSB please join me in welcoming Lord
John Brown
[Music]
dean levin and ladies and gentlemen the
year was 1969 and i was contemplating my
future my father's advice was very clear
go and get a real job he meant a job in
industry british petroleum that
sponsored me as an undergraduate and
paid me to work there during the
vacations but i was much more interested
in pursuing academic research and in any
case industry was frowned upon inside
the ancient walls of the university of
cambridge so I told my father I do have
a real job it's called research and with
apologies to the members of the faculty
here today my father replied no I mean a
real job so I relented agreeing to join
BP on the condition that they sent me to
the United States and on the assumption
that I would only be there for a year or
two before returning to Cambridge as it
turned out I found myself 200 miles
north of the Arctic Circle working in
Point Barrow Alaska this was not quite
what I had had in mind but this didn't
stop me from staying at BP for more than
a year indeed for a career that would
span more than four decades
fast-forward to California in 1997 when
I joined the board of directors of Intel
Corporation the company's CEO at the
time was the late great Andy Grove who
was one of my great mentors and
inspirations like me he had Jewish
relatives who'd fled the horrors of
mid-century Europe and like me before he
became a businessman he trained as an
engineer and he once told me that as an
immigrant who spoke terrible English he
chose to study engineering because he
thought it was the only subject in which
his examiners would assess him fairly
in other words and he believed
engineering to be a rational subject
will the bridge stay up or fall down
does the computer program work or does
it crash with no room for value
judgments there will be no room for
prejudice or bias but even with the best
of intentions we build our human biases
and flaws into the fabric of our
creations we forget that the
technologies we introduced in the into
the world will have unpredictable
effects on the lives of real people
for example opioid painkillers can
relieve suffering but can also cause
addiction hydrocarbons lift people out
of poverty but their use is dangerously
altering the Earth's climate and new
levels of connectivity have made it
possible to communicate with anyone
anywhere at any time but may have
destroyed privacy these innovations are
all products of engineering but their
impact on society is determined by the
way in which they're used so Andy Grove
was only half right engineers can't be
assessed through rationality alone
because everything they do involves a
value judgment and a choice about
whether and how to innovate and in any
case I soon learned that no engineering
solution is complete unless it results
in something practical that humanity and
the market wants this naturally led me
into business and here to Stanford I
arrived here when almost every business
person was obsessed with shareholder
value theory this told us that the duty
of business leaders was to make as much
money as possible for their shareholders
without going to jail it reduced
business to a mere process an object of
rationality and it contributed to the
damaging impression the company's are
driven by self-interest
and indifferent to the needs of those
around them but Stanford helped me
understand why that theory was
incomplete guided by an incomparable
faculty I saw the business could not be
conducted in isolation from society
public policy and human feelings
business turned out to be a wonderful
weave of numbers and people like
engineering it was about much more than
mere rationality so where does that
leave you as business leaders it
certainly makes your job much more
difficult you cannot simply muddle
through by managing the status quo
business is about much more much more
than administering the advent of the
inevitable it's about exercising
judgment and it's about putting people
and society at the heart of every
decision you make these were my
ambitions as a CEO there were moments
when I succeeded and moments when I
failed and I once shared two of those
moments just now the first took place
here at Stanford on a scorching May
morning in 1997 I delivered a speech in
the frost amphitheater in which I became
the first big oil CEO to acknowledge the
link between anthropogenic carbon
emissions and climate change I announced
our decision to go beyond analysis to
seek to suit solutions and to take
action we committed to invest in the
development of alternative fuels and
energies and we pledged to advocate and
advance big global solutions such as a
carbon tax
now that speech opened BP up to attack
from absolutely every direction
environmental lobby groups thought we'd
not gone far enough while the American
Petroleum Institute said that BP had
left the church but within a decade the
oil and gas industry had stopped denying
climate
and BP had led the way the strategic
shift was the product of almost a decade
of listening to bait and persuasion we
spoke to President Clinton Governor
George W Bush NGOs such as the Pew
Center and the world's leading
scientists and experts one of my closest
confidence was my expense then Dean of
the school who provided the most
valuable sounding board and we spoke to
BP employees to who of course were also
consumers voters and parents concerned
about their family's future by taking a
lead on climate change we changed the
way people thought about BP we attracted
a new group of leaders who would never
have considered a career in the energy
industry and we created the foundation
of a successful renewable and
alternative energy business we focused
on developing relevant solutions to new
challenges we put people society and the
environment as well as shareholder value
at the heart of our business two decades
later
I regret that there is still much to do
the probability of an existential threat
to humanity is rising renewable energy
is supplying a growing share of global
energy demand but it will not replace
fossil fuels certainly not in my
lifetime and possibly not even in yours
this means that we must use technologies
such as carbon capture and storage to
take the carbon out of hydrocarbons we
know how to do this we have all the
technologies we need it's now a question
of getting the right policies the right
behaviors and the right incentives so
that solutions can be deployed globally
at scale and ever decreasing cost above
all it's a question of harnessing the
power of business to deliver what is
good for society
so bp's experience with climate change
was i believe an example of successfully
changing direction we leaned in to a
great upheaval
in science engineering and behavior
which is still taking place but in my
personal life in one very important area
I fail to keep up with the pace of
change my mother an Auschwitz survivor
gave me two pieces of advice the first
was that when the going gets tough the
majority always hurt the minority so
it's better not to be an identifiable
member of a minority the second was not
to tell anyone your secrets because they
will surely use them against you this
advice was born from her own painful
experience applied to my own life it
meant that I chose to keep my sexuality
a secret it was easy at first I had two
lives a private life and a work life it
was exciting
a bit like being James Bond with a
legend and a reality in some respects
this painful separation taught me
something I was good at reading people
and sensing danger but as I rose up in
the ranks of BP I became more
recognizable and this behavior became
riskier I was in meshed in conservative
corporate and political cultures and was
worried that any disclosure would damage
business relationships
so my work became my life and BP became
my extended family when my mother died I
lost my closest companion became very
lonely I foolishly thought that rather
than openly openly seeking a partner
that would be safer to find one secretly
online that was my first mistake and it
was followed by several further serious
errors of judgment in 2007 I was outed
by a British newspaper
and then I decided to resign from B be a
CEO one of my primary responsibilities
was to lead through inclusion that means
creating teams in which everyone has a
stake in the future
it also means instilling self belief in
people and demonstrating to them that
they can be included while being
themselves the ways in which our
workforce changed while I was CEO
suggested that we were doing something
right but the practice of inclusion is
so much easier when you have role models
who demonstrate that it's possible to
succeed while being yourself by
remaining in the closet I failed to be a
role model when it when it came to a
personal and authentic leadership the
world around me had changed and I'd not
recognize that change these big
experiences demonstrate two things the
first is that we don't have to be
passive when faced with a world which
makes us feel lost and powerless there
are things we can change even if it
takes time on climate change public
debate has shifted dramatically in the
past 20 years it shifted because people
said that what they believed and worked
hard to convince others I'm proud of
being part of that process
and I only wish it had moved more
quickly attitudes to being gay have
changed too because people stood up and
had pride in themselves and in who they
are I regret not being one of those
people sooner my second conclusion is
that being different is a strength
business and indeed any other walk of
life is not populated by robots
programmed to think and act in a
standardized way a successful business
is a company a group of different people
with different experiences and skills
that in an inclusive way who come
together for a common purpose difference
is what the world expects of every
Stanford GSB graduate it expects you to
challenge norms rather than to obey them
it expects you to be yourselves and to
shape and reshape the world rather than
to conform to its expectations it
expects you to think deeply act boldly
dream widely for these are the qualities
of great leaders and great organizations
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of all
GSB alumni I congratulate you and wish
you a wonderful day of celebration thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
it is now my great honor and pleasure to
introduce the GSB PhD class of 2019
our ph.d program is small and exclusive
with an admission rate well under 10%
these individuals came here as students
dedicating themselves to two or three
years of coursework followed by an
intensive research apprenticeship in
their chosen fields having become true
experts they leave us as colleagues
setting out on a path to create new
knowledge which we know will help change
the world of business and management for
the better today we formally celebrate
the transition of these folks from
students to future intellectual leaders
who will play an important role in
shaping our understanding of business
and management after their advisors
place the hood of the Stanford Graduate
School of Business on them they will
join us on the stage as we welcome them
as colleagues into our profession Diane
Lee executive director of the ph.d
program will now read their names and
their dissertation advisor will hood
them
yeah booze atcha Colin Yahoo's studies
the influence of emotions on consumer
behavior on yui ways research focus on
focuses on over-the-counter financial
markets specifically how dealers trade
bonds with customers and with other
dealers nathan atkinson nate studies how
legal rules can be designed to better
align the interests of corporations and
society
Melanie Brooks
Melanie's research focuses on how to
structure idea generation activities to
maximize innovation Thomas chose
[Applause]
Thomas's research models the emergence
of ambiguities in the text of laws
enacted by legislators Robert Donnelly
[Applause]
Rob's research provides improved models
on learning how consumers make choices
when faced with a large number of
options
Kristian Fong
[Applause]
Christiane's research focuses on
congressional leadership and rules the
jad site dad's Wade's research focuses
on how investors allocate their
attention and how that impacts the
functioning of markets the when how when
house research explores how quantitative
easing policies by the Federal Reserve
affect the US banking system and the
broader economy the child
[Applause]
jazz studies American politics with a
focus on campaign finance Giorgio
martini Georgia studies how to design
markets where information and
preferences rather than money determine
who gets what
Joshua Morris
[Applause]
Josh examines how the pain associated
with parting with money affects a person
spending budgeting and investing
decisions Roy Roth Roy's research
identifies imperfections in the market
for venture capital financing such as
excessive optimism and misaligned
incentives and explores the effects
these have on funding patterns
Shen yuan yuan yuan ones research
focuses on engagement drivers in a
lending marketplace
[Applause]
Brian shoe
Brian's research explores how corporate
decision-making and public finance
policy affect household labor market
outcomes doyoung yoon doyoung studies
how to optimally schedule medical
appointments and design treatment policy
to significantly reduce patient's worst
case life years
Jessica you Jessica studies consumer
behavior in online markets and its
implications for platform design
[Applause]
good afternoon on this festive and
beautiful day it is my real pleasure as
director of the Stanford MSX program to
present this year's graduates who will
receive the degree of Master of Science
and management the mission of the MSX
program is to provide experienced
leaders men and women who have spent at
least eight years in professional and
management roles the opportunity to
prepare themselves for increasingly
senior positions in organizations they
will leave the program is a full-time
year-long course of academic study
giving these students an all-too-rare
chance for reflection and growth in the
midst of an already accomplished career
on behalf of the administration of the
program and the faculty you have taught
them join me in wishing each of them
great fulfillment and success in the
next phase of their careers
in honor of the service of former GSB
Dean Robert Joss who is himself a
Stanford Sloan fellow the top 10% of the
MSX class ranked by academic performance
are designated as Robert Shaw scholars
as we read the names of the graduates we
will also announce that they have
achieved the distinction of Robert Shaw
scholar I will now read the graduates
names while Dean Levin presents the
diplomas a set AB do I leave Anoosh
Agarwal
karun on
Jason Han Wei Bay
Robert Shaw scholar Rohit Bala Robert
Josh scholar
Nick Blasi
Jack sigh
[Applause]
Adriel cha
Sahra cheery Mar
[Music]
William Chong
Felipe Corsi me Mota Amir dodged emoji
Felipe de moosie
Dwan chalet
Judy Dunbar Sarah June Ericsson Umberto
Oscar peeny
Mota's Bakri Fabien galvo Garces wen
dong
Megan Elizabeth Goering Robert Shaw
scholar Sri Gandhi
[Music]
[Applause]
Miguel cravat
mohnish iike Gupta
I mean howdy big Samantha Hagar bomber
Robert Shaw scholar
you hear Yama Henry Xiang
Jeremy James Joseph
carlos roberto Hoebel ghujiya Mike
Kearns
max Kendrick
chin song John Kim Robert an hour
Mansingh Lee Phil Lee Lee Lee
Zhi Hao Lin Hui min Liu ji you
[Applause]
looting
je ma - Mona mapa loose
Mariah's Darsh Preet Singh Mondeo Co
Maruyama in Knowles Nick Milan
my aunt Miss Robin
[Applause]
Aki Mia Sokka
Matthew Napoli
[Applause]
and win
a beer not nosh made Victor awesome it's
joon-young park
jitka Guha quake court a
Israel Rana
Diego Saraiva
Yosuke sassa Jima Damona
Shibata
[Applause]
again Kenny shintani
Sumeet Sinha
Neal Spackman
Oriana Straubel PI and ton robert shaw
scholar Ian Taylor Tiffany Jane Chen
[Applause]
Eric Michael juicy wits
Robert Shaw scholar Frank we pert Robert
Josh scholar Brett Wilson Robert Josh
scholar Thomas Wilson
[Applause]
Karen whoo Xander whoosh way Lamia
you said hi hi UN Bowen Jang Joey
zou
Jaggi Jew is now my pleasure to
introduce senior associate dean Yossi
Feinberg
among the Robert el Josh scholars one
student's academic achievement places
them at the top of the MSX class
this student is awarded the George GC
Parker prized named in honor of GSB
faculty and former program director
professor George Parker who is here
today the Graduate receives a
certificate the cash award and the name
will be on a plaque displayed at the GSB
the recipient of the 2019 George Parker
prize is Brett Wilson
[Applause]
distinguished guests faculty members
staff families and friends the MBA
students gathered before us today have
engaged in that transformational
experience they've acquired solid
foundations in general management and
have pursued deeper study in their areas
of interest they have engaged in
personal growth and built relationships
that will last a lifetime
they've helped the school and the
community in many ways they are an
impressive group and are ready and
worthy to join the ranks of our
illustrious alumni therefore it is my
great honor and privilege to present to
you the Stanford MBA class of 2019
as you leave I hope your memories of the
GSB will remain fresh and that you will
stay involved with the school
our alumni played an important role in
your academic experience ranging from
serving as judges in its executive
challenge to acting as mentors in
intrapreneurial classes it is my wish
that you too will engage with the GSB
academic mission as alumni and give your
time and experience generously to future
classes your class has already
demonstrated its desire to stay
connected to the GSB and to support the
school in a meaningful way through your
participation in the class gift campaign
you will live your own legacy and play a
part in bringing the GSB experience
to future generations as other alumni
have done before you all of you have
undoubtedly heard of RJ Miller RJ served
in the US Air Force during the Second
World War and was later one of the
so-called whiz kids who revolutionized
Ford Motor Company RJ became President
Ford and then later the much admired
fourth Dean of the GSB in honor of Dean
Miller's service the top 10% of the
class ranked by academic performance are
designated that are as RJ Miller scholar
x' as we heard the names as we hear the
names of the graduates we will also
announce that they have achieved the
academic distinction of RJ Miller
scholar in case like every pulse in the
GSB those qualifications right in case
of joint degree students who are
currently walking but are yet to
graduate we will identify those who are
currently the top 10% of the class the
late did Miller is also founded the
certificate in public management and
social innovation program at the GSB the
certificate program educates leaders who
understand social issues designed for
and evaluate impact and understand the
specificities of the management of
social organizations in both private and
public sectors today specific
certificate graduates take the spirit of
our GSB motto change lives change
organizations change the world to its
full potential this year we have a
hundred and nine recipients the names
are listed in the commencement program
graduate names will now be read by
Margaret Hayes assistant dean of the MBA
and MSX programs and by Kirsten Moss
assistant dean of the Emmet MBA
admissions and financial aid graduates
will receive the diplomas from Dean
Levin Margaret and Kristen please
[Music]
Cave Abercrombie Jessica have known
isola a Depot Jew Matthew James Agnew a
poor of agrawal RJ Miller scholar
Alejandro McGee De Marco Alban otago
collude all the ball
Jane Elizabeth Alexander Justin Amaro at
mesquita
cavort Amir Jan jaan
Nicole Appleton Kristen Archer
Julio Armand RTS Castillo Ruben long
Arnold
Benton Atchison Julia Rose nd Ava buck
Gabriel Benjamin avens Morgan bear
Robert Bailey
Turab Oshawa
Annie Baldwin top 10% of the current
class
Blair Janssen bollard Deepak Bonsall
crotch evanthia
Steven Donahue barber Mohammad Berk
Ashley
Kate Bartlett
Hilary Susan Bartlett Steven BAE
Jamie beaten RJ Miller scholar
Ryan Scott Beck
I'd hoop change that bellacor Yasmine
Belarus OGG a Mercedes bent Marissa and
Berta rally
[Applause]
Stephen barriner
Eric Davis Bloome entrants
Leon borma Emily booth RJ Miller scholar
pierre bouvier Anthony browser
andia my apprentice
mark
brenson Buhari
Ave Odin Rossi you Eleanor Buckingham
marry Buckland
Nicole but since key buyers RJ Miller
scholar
Jeffrey Calder RJ Miller scholar
John Anthony Cardozo
Michael Andrew Karen Christopher Thomas
Carper Mauricio Carbajal
Elya chain daniel Chernov
Malcolm piles jalaja
Jacqueline Chang
Jian Chen
Sasha Chen
Sophia Chen Elena Chen
when chain race chain
Stacy Christensen david chung daeun
cinnamon caroline Clark Ian Clark
Samuel William Clayman Deirdre clue
Andrew Cohen
Kate Cooper Callie FAFSA Conrad Carl
Joseph coaching you Tomas crew RJ Miller
scholar
Haley chase crown Daniela kunio Ainsley
Daigle Ross Darwin Robert Davies
Patrick to pray Gallagher Shawn Davila
chin Chandi Shiro Delano
jean-paul Bricker Dillard
[Music]
sheriff Nemer DZ
Amanda Donahue Hansen Natalie Burris
Doyle
Benjamin Ross Dre
Matthew Herndon Dugan
Samuel Henry Dula RJ Miller scholar
Samantha Camille
Ely Charlotte Hersh Edelson
Alexandra Edmonds Sarah ecozy
yawn Eifler
[Applause]
d metal mosh muck
Parker ends
mariya English
Rosario ara suddha sattva gotta John
Tyler injure RJ Miller scholar
Cody Evans ran fan
[Applause]
Kenneth Quinn song
James McGinnis Harbor Erika Feldhausen
Josh Feldman
Sam Fisher
Edward Benjamin Fishman RJ Miller
scholar
li p ja Fishman William Justin foils
Rhea Forbes
Andreea Fox
dan freeman robert walker fuller
Tomas Garcia squared Oh
mahat Sumanth guard Joseph Gargery ah no
Joan English gas
RIA Gaius seen
Catherine Joan guess Gorman
Caroline GZ Alam Khiladi Noga go long
Jennifer Goldman
sarah michelle Goodison
Massimiliano gory
Christopher grant
i Greenstein
Jake Evan Greenstein RJ Miller scholar
Christina Susan gogo
Nicholas p.m. Annika Gupta
Joseph Daniel Gutierrez
daniela lute Lansky
Rodolfo Guzman
Fernando Guzman Elizondo
Jase Hoffner
Rahul Michael Hajjar
Emma Francis Henley
Jennifer Lee Harris
Meredith Holton posi
Trent posi RJ Miller scholar
EDA bell temple Talia Elena
Hernandez Duran Dionisio era
namu Kaaba pillow
Sarah Hoffman
Doug Colin
James Edward fault
the second
David Charles Hoyt
ciao poit
Catherine Yellen Wong
Nicholas Lyle peppered Yvette Houston
Achmed Ibrahim
[Applause]
Nelson you gonna lock
Jeremy nicodemus Intel
Moe Islam
Lauren Nicole Jackson
ah hey Jane
are you Jane
today yeah James
[Applause]
Nicholas Andrew Jankowski RJ Miller
scholar
Julia yes carska
Alejandro Paso
jonathan jean-pierre
[Applause]
Matthew Jensen
desertion Jim Cameron
octi John
Larson Jones
Sam Jones
Daniel Raymond Jeff Lewis Conrad chug
[Applause]
kadoya Yoshitaka
ah fishy Samir
Taji Roland called tuff RJ Miller
scholar
engineer sink and Ola
[Applause]
Katrina and Cardus aqus late Cavanaugh
Kendra koala Ian Patrick Nichols Kelly
David Benjamin Royce Kemper
[Applause]
say leap a cat loon
Alicia pies
[Applause]
Sophia Salma Khalifa Schramko
Jin Yong Kim
Nicole Kim
[Applause]
Charles Kitzinger
Katrina Baron Klein J Piniella
Jeffrey Tucker Koecher RJ Miller scholar
Anna Conan Aras constantan Edie's
Joshua Kornberg
Brian
Richard krump
[Applause]
Matias Lanos
hi me Lorraine
Louise last Corrine
David Lee Raffaelli
Lai Chi RJ Miller scholar
Andrew Lewis RJ Miller scholar
then Len
Helen Lee ten belly
RJ Miller scholar
ginger liao
ami lefland Helen Lynn
q Lin Ellen Lu
RJ Miller scholar
that's blue Mimi ung leo
Liara Lockhart
Francisco Lopes
mara Luckman
[Applause]
Scott Robert Lowenstein RJ Miller
scholar
tawanda Michael Meharry my aunt Mehrotra
Bob Mann Frieda RJ Miller scholar
Tess Manning
swappi man Oh Robbie
Sara and Catherine Philips
Martin
[Applause]
Andrew Benjamin Matunga txc airman
Mattia
Bridget meanie Evan Mian
the meta Mensa
we'll Miller
Julie mints
daveed Nero yo piss
Josh met Roni
she um Yogesh Modi RJ Miller scholar
Chad Monroe Talley Murphy Austin
murkland rant Nellie mussalam Jen
Nakamura
anuraag nama potty Zana Manisha Gabriela
neder
Miette Newman
[Applause]
Jennifer Nye cute and win
[Music]
[Applause]
shall tune me Julian Nix
Siddarth Kalpana mahendra Anisha RJ
Miller scholar
Justin Gregory Norton née boss Nanta
[Applause]
Nancy crystal a Casilla adoro
Johannes Elena
tyese elevator aundrea almost Nakamura
Naomi walling Juliana Jasmine Ortega
Henry oars in ski trap no David ASEAN
day Julia Isabel Osterman Casey Hughes
Oswald
Elizabeth pan Luke patent
Jessica Renee Patton Devon pence
James Payne RJ Miller scholar
Danielle pence at William Edward
Pirozhki
Simone Gabrielle Peron
Anna
Pino Mariana yada Pia Pia jomkwan
Kevin Manuel Koehler
Joanne poon
[Music]
huge party
been project
Andrew Sidney preeminence Trevor Slocum
profit Alexandra Robert prudence
Lauren Christine prize and Veronica
poutine
Simon chin RJ Miller scholar
joon-kyu will Quinn McMahon Alison
rejewski
[Applause]
Karolina Rakolta
begone ramen Neethu Vaisala Mirage
Vineet Rajan
Rodrigo Ramos
I did your run Jenny Luna Jia Xin chào
[Applause]
James Philip Roth Mel jr. RJ Miller
scholar
courtney lynn ready
xavier Redondo a less true 8 RJ Miller
scholar
Charles rice
[Applause]
Dane Renner Michelle Renta
immersion ray RJ Miller scholar
Sam Murray
well Alexander Ritter Katherine Maria
Rivera
Patrick Robinson RJ Miller scholar
Victoria Rodgers Shawn Rosenberg
Betty Ilana Rosenfield
[Applause]
Jacqueline Claire Rahman
Dawid rukon z
and Katherine Rutherford
Michael Joseph Ryan RJ Miller scholar
Camille Amin Mohammad Sayeed servyse
Anka
[Applause]
[Music]
Aylmer Santos Adriel Saporta Camilla que
sabe Hoshi
Christopher Carl Scheer
Daniel Schiller mark Schiff ski Patrick
Thomas schneller Sean Arthur Schroeder
Michael Schwartz RJ Miller scholar
Mitchell Scott
Brian Scullin Taylor Siva harine Vijay
Shah mallanna hostile Shapira Sam
Shapiro RJ Miller scholar
- Bianca Sharma
Noah Matthew Sheinbaum valoración top
10% of current class Dennis sure I
dust nursing Tanya Sofia
Cisco saggy
Tyler Johnston Paulie Smith
Samantha Smith Epstein er
Helen Hosanna Solomon Michael Joseph
Solomon Alice song RJ Miller scholar
juyeon songs
[Music]
it's gay son mas Patrick stuffer
yelling Stern Jacob Stern
Tanner Strickland
the RICO Sucre Anderson sue Marley Ethan
son
Rachel Lauren Sussman
Jan late acasi Rio tani RJ Miller
scholar
Raji Terry Gopala
Elana Teitelbaum
Peter triple lock Hannah she knew a TN
Norris lead on tea
hero T and
[Applause]
Radhika t molten Katherine Sydney topper
Eric track
[Applause]
Brian Prescott Triana
Salo francelina Trista
Vinay Trivedi
Karen Underwood ray Hannon Vasily
Tucker patron benek and RJ Miller
scholar
Ellen Vanessa RJ Miller scholar Juan de
Vargas Lopez
sebastian Velez agneta then put ramen
Adam Marcus they're hustled Derek Walker
RJ Miller scholar
have Walters
[Applause]
[Music]
April Bowen Wang
Chris Wong
night changwon you Benjamin ward
Andrew James Wardle James Wang Kate
Owens Wharton Kevin Thomas white RJ
Miller scholar David Williams
Tylar Willebrand
David whiner
Aaron David wind God
Alison was Nevsky
Daisy whoa
[Music]
Ashley woodruf
gram rookie phocion whoo
Owen words bucker RJ Miller scholar
samya yada Sahil yak me
[Applause]
Katie yang Lakshmi Chitra yaar ligado
Andrew we don't you take June you RJ
Miller scholar
Bruno Yoshimura Terry you go Rozlyn yo
Jim you Ian
Hollis
Pablo Zapata era rambu Paulo
[Applause]
Anna is like saya Tina
Eric zong RJ Miller scholar
Julianne jay-z song zy Joe
ray song
Steph you Chen Zhong Li or Asha Z Chrome
hilary rosen jack Simic Arielle zib
[Applause]
nominated and chosen by their peers the
recipient of the Ernst C Arbuckle award
is the second year MBA student who by
their active participation initiative
leadership and personal integrity is
judged as having contributed most to the
fulfillment of the goals of the Stanford
Graduate School of Business in their
actions both within school and in
society the recipient receives a cash
prize and also has their name on a
plaque on display at the GSB we are
delighted to have Susan Arbuckle
the daughter of Ernie Arbuckle
with us today to deliver the award this
year recipient of the award is Julianne
jay-z's on
the Alexander a Rabi check student
achievement award in finance was
established to honor professor orbit
checks outstanding contribution to the
teaching of finance at the GSB from 1960
until his death in 1978 the award is
given to an MBA student selected by the
finance faculty for outstanding
achievement in the finance courses the
recipient receives the award and also
has the name on a plaque or display at
the GSB and we are delighted that mark
Robert jack professor Robert Jackson is
here today to deliver the award this
year recipient of the award is owen wood
Parker
[Applause]
among their RJ Miller scholar 'he's one
student academic achievement places them
at the top of the class this student is
designated as the Henry for the second
scholar and receives along with the
Miller scholar
scroll a significant cash award
and their name on a plaque displayed at
the GSB
it is a musical isn't it this year's
recipient of the award is Jeffrey Tucker
culture
[Applause]
honored guests faculty staff families
and friends we have reached the
conclusion of our ceremony I invite you
to join us for receptions of the knight
Management Center as soon as the
ceremony ends gred which is now
graduates please stand
[Applause]
what a journey it has been before we
walk out one last time into the
California Sun and celebrate let's have
one more round of applause to recognize
the GSB class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]